he-man has become a pop culture icon
with his magic sword defending his home
planet of eternia but did you know he
came from star wars toys or that he once
became shazam here's the untold truth
about he-man and the masters of the
universe the 1980s saw a major explosion
in action figures this was largely due
to the star wars film franchise and the
popular figurines of characters like
luke skywalker and darth vader made by
kenner toys surprisingly however kenner
wasn't the first toy company that
received an offer to produce star wars
toys in 1976 ray wagner the ceo of
mattel incorporated declined george
lucas's asking price of 750 000 to
produce a toy line of star wars action
figures wagner undoubtedly ended up
regretting the decision when the toys
became one of the most lucrative parts
of the film franchise mattel then
quickly launched several medieval and
science fiction themed toy lines of
their own they hoped to create the next
hit action figure in the bargain
according to the book mastering the
universe he-man and the rise and fall of
a billion dollar idea roger sweet a
designer at mattel decided on the
generic name he-man to build a toy line
around although none of the aspects of
he-man's mythology had been developed
yet the simplicity of the name was key
this gave the company's team of
designers a mostly blank canvas that
they could use to create virtually any
story world they imagined
today it's impossible to separate the
name he-man from the image of a
massively muscled blonde barbarian but
when mattel began developing the he-man
concept the toy line could have gone in
any number of different directions at
one point mattel executives were given a
choice between three prototype models of
he-man a barbarian a soldier and a
science fiction hero weirdly the sci-fi
version of he-man wore a helmet that
looked very much like the mandalorian
helmet worn by boba fett in the empire
strikes back but the helmet reappeared
in a recent version of vikran in the
masters of the universe classics line
ultimately the barbarian version of
he-man proved the most appealing to the
executives the he-man and the masters of
the universe backstory then went on to
become a sword and sorcery epic however
it's strange to think that at one point
he-man could have been mattel's version
of a mandalorian lucasfilm likely
wouldn't care for the design though so
it's lucky that he-man decided to bear
his distinctive page boy haircut and
tanned face to the world
seeing how he-man and the masters of the
universe developed from a toy line into
an animated series is interesting
because it reveals how he-man's story
world has been regularly reimagined
mattel included a mini comic with its
action figures that helped flesh out the
character's backstories originally
he-man was a barbarian from an eternian
tribe that existed in a post-apocalyptic
world armed with advanced weaponry
he-man defended castle greyskull from
his enemy skeletor interestingly he-man
and skeletor both possessed half of the
original power sword which reflected the
way kids could combine the action figure
swords into one by 1983 mattel had
partnered with filmmation to develop a
he-man cartoon that provided he-man's
most popular origin now he was prince
adam of eternia who had been endowed
with the power to transform into he-man
using the power sword this power was
given to him by the sorceress of castle
greyskull adam could also turn his
cowardly pat cringer into the fearsome
battle cat and fought with his allies
against skeletor's forces other cartoons
continued tweaking he-man's origin in
the new adventures of he-man he-man was
summoned to the future to defend mankind
reviving his science fiction roots in
the 2002 he-man and the masters of the
universe reboot adam was a spoiled teen
who reluctantly became he-man to rescue
his kingdom from skeletor while most
animated series keep the most popular
beats there's always room for some
revision he-man may be eternia's
greatest champion but he has roots in
another world earth according to the
1980s cartoon series prince adam's
mother queen marlena was an astronaut
from earth who crash landed on eternia
and ended up marrying the planet's king
randor one episode the rainbow warrior
referenced marlena's piloting skills but
she was mostly relegated to being a
background player in 1985 the made for
tv animated film he-man and she-ra a
christmas special was released in the
film greyskull's jester orco
accidentally travels to earth during
christmas time something tells me i'm in
big trouble
the eternian magician brings back a
couple of earth children causing queen
marlena to reminisce about christmas
prince adam actually got to play santa
claus at one point showing how marlena
had been influencing eternia's culture
most interestingly however it turns out
the earth that marlena is from also
exists in the dc universe this can be
seen in dc comics presents number 47
where he-man acknowledges marlena told
him stories about superman the protector
of her homeworld both he-man and his
alter-ego prince adam were voiced by
john irwin in the 1980s cartoon irwin
gave he-man a majestic authoritative
voice while giving adam a more laid-back
attitude we have no time to lose by the
power of grey scars
this helped differentiate the two
personas even though the show's original
character designs made the two of them
look identical save for he-man's darker
tan beyond he-man irwin has an
impressive list of live-action and voice
acting credits to his name including
roles in rawhide back to the future 2
and babe however his most famous role
was morris the cat the feline
spokesperson and face of 9 lives cat
food during the 1970s
yep the voice of he-man got famous
delivering snarky lines as a fat orange
cat who rivaled garfield in deadpan
humor with lines like who says i need
improving the he-man cartoon probably
missed out on a golden opportunity to
also cast irwin as he-man's feline steed
battle cat but he was voiced by
celebrated voice actor alan oppenheimer
he-man may look like a warrior straight
out of the sword and sorcery epics of
conan the barbarian but the 1980s
cartoon went out of its way to show him
dealing with problems non-violently
while he was capable of lifting
mountains and pushing a moon out of
orbit he-man rarely used his great
strength to hurt people plus he usually
limited his punching targets to robots
or buildings many episodes showed him
using diplomacy to convince potential
enemies to change their ways he even got
damar the demon king to reconsider
invading eternia in the episode demar
the demon a lot of this is likely due to
the producers wanting parents to believe
the cartoon would teach their children
good values so they could keep watching
the show and buying the toys much like
gi joe the episodes even regularly ended
with a moral prince adam tila or the
other characters instructed viewers on
the importance of telling the truth or
working problems out by asking for help
superheroes typically wear a symbol or
emblem that represents their power from
superman's s-shaped family crest to
batman's bat totem in he-man's case the
character designers initially placed an
iron cross in the center of his chest
harness to enhance his distinctive look
the problem was the iron cross was
appropriated by the nazi party who
placed a swastika symbol in its center
notably the swastika itself is an
ancient symbol that had been used as a
symbol of well-being by many societies
before adolf hitler appropriated it for
the nazi flag as a result any positive
connotations of these symbols have been
overshadowed by their negative use and
they continue to be employed as a hate
symbol by extremist groups today
naturally he-man didn't wear a swastika
on his iron cross and being a hero of
the planet eternia the symbol likely
meant something different but it was
eventually realized that his chest
emblem could get people thinking the
wrong thing because of this more modern
depictions of he-man have modified the
iron cross into an h symbol mattel came
out with a lot of creative action
figures when it developed the original
he-man toy line but the weirdest
characters were members of skeletor's
entourage many of them particularly evil
lin and beastman went on to become major
figures in the animated series one
action figure was so ridiculous the
story editors vowed to never use him in
the cartoon that would be stingcore a
humanoid skunk whose power was that he
smelled really bad and gave off toxic
odors mattel manufactured the toy to
intentionally smell bad by treating it
with musky smelling patchouli oil and
then it earned a reputation for stinking
up toy boxes nationwide stingor's action
figure also came with a mini comic the
stench of evil where he attacked he-man
with his horrible body odor but when the
character was presented to the filmation
staff they reportedly burst out laughing
and decided to keep him out of their
scripts stinkor finally made it to
television in the 2002 he-man cartoon
reboot where it was revealed that he was
once a thief who became mutated by a
chemical accident notably stinkor isn't
noseblind to his stink and must wear an
oxygen mask making his ability one of
the worst superpowers to have
while he-man was marketed toward boys
girls liked the masters of the universe
too mattel decided to capitalize on this
by creating he-man's twin sister adora
aka shira she was given her own toy line
and an animated series called shira
princess of power shira defended the
world of etherea from the evil horde
after being given a sort of protection
that imbued her with superhuman strength
speed durability and agility although
she-ra was established as he-man's
physical equal she may have been his
superior in at least one respect her
sort of protection could transform into
anything she required various episodes
of her cartoon showed she-ra turning the
sword into a rope a shield a boomerang a
magnet and even an ice maker frankly by
the time shira started turning her sword
into a parachute things got a little
ridiculous
while fans may now look back on the
original he-man animated series with
fondness many admit the cartoon's plots
could get a little silly filmmation
managed to get some serious talent
working on these episodes however and
many of their staff members went on to
have major careers in dc and marvel
comics bruce tim and paul deeney the
minds behind the dc animated universe
that included the award-winning batman
the animated series batman beyond and
justice league unlimited got their start
on the he-man cartoon tim worked as a
background artist and layout designer
who also wrote he-man mini comics deeney
was a script writer for the cartoon and
wrote episodes such as quest for he-man
where he-man was rendered amnesic and
banished to a contaminated planet to
teach kids about the dangers of
pollution likewise j michael strzenski
who had runs on the amazing spider-man
and fantastic four for marvel comics
served as the story editor for both
he-man and she-ra it might not be as
slick as today's animated series but for
many he-man and the masters of the
universe helped pave the modern age of
superhero animated shows
he-man may be the most powerful man in
the universe but how does he stack up
against the other most powerful hero in
the universe superman as it turns out
the comics have addressed this question
multiple times dc comics presents number
47 saw superman transported to eternia
by a mystic cloud where he met up with
he-man although the two started out as
allies skeletor was able to take magical
control of superman and pit him against
he-man while it looked like superman had
the upper hand he was able to shake off
skeletor's control and break off his
attack however superman and he-man had a
much more brutal fight in the injustice
versus masters of the universe
miniseries that came out in 2018 it took
place in the injustice universe where
superman became the dictator of earth
the story saw several dc heroes journey
to eternia and recruit he-man to fight
the man of steel while he-man's mystical
power allowed him to pummel superman
some manipulation by skeletor caused
he-man to lose his connection to
greyskull's magic this caused him to
revert back to prince adam leaving him
at the mercy of superman who considered
him less of a threat than captain carrot
he-man is often compared to conan the
barbarian but there's one other
superhero he shares a lot in common with
billy batson aka the dc hero known as
shazam or captain marvel like billy
prince adam is a young man imbued with
mystical powers that allow him to become
a mighty hero superman himself made this
connection in the injustice versus
masters of the universe miniseries and
fortunately for adam so did a certain
wizard during the course of the story
skeletor managed to steal the power of
shazam and attempted to use it to
conquer eternia instead he got himself
killed and inadvertently passed the
power of the gods to prince adam who was
summoned before the wizard as his new
champion by simply shouting shazam adam
transformed into a white garbed being
with similarities to both shazam and
he-man newly empowered the shazam he-man
made short work of the corrupt injustice
superman it was a scene bursting with
fanboy energy although he-man later went
back to his standard look and powers
while this might disappoint some
crossover fans when you're already the
most powerful man in the universe being
a super strong barbarian is enough
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]